this story really hits home for me
um many of you know this past year I um
I was diagnosed with colon cancer
still very strange to say
just a few months ago I under underwent
surgery they removed about 35 percent of
my colon
I'm
healthy
a little fatter than I probably should
be but overall very healthy have great
blood pressure
all signs are great
so cancer snuck up on me
and it is tough nobody deserves it uh if
I wouldn't wish it on anybody it was a
very rough road to recovery
um I don't know how to categorize it
whether I almost lost my life or I could
have lost my life but it was it was
close
given if not for
um my my wife's concern
I might not be here given if not for her
convincing me
to go to the doctor I
it would have been curtains
for JD
so this story does hit home for me Jamie
Raskin
a beautiful man
congressman from a neighboring area
right here in Washington DC in Maryland
has been diagnosed with lymphoma
because I've just been introduced to to
cancer having it I don't know all the
different kinds I don't know exactly
which which which variety of lymphoma he
has
but he was in a committee
and he has now a bandana on his head
because he's undergoing chemotherapy and
there was an uncharacteristic and I
think wonderful
uh display by James Comer excuse me the
committee chairman
and they they're talking to him about
how they're going to pray for him and
really show it was an outpouring of
support uncharacteristic in these
political times and I I just I wanted to
talk about it and play it for you
because not only is it beautiful and
something we should strive for to be
able to work together
um I think that if you are a Praying
person if you are a Karma person if you
are an energy person if you are a good
vibes person you should send them to
Congressman Jamie Raskin because he and
his family absolutely
are in need of it
watch this clip
that I yield to the distinguished
gentleman from Maryland ranking member
Jamie Raskin to introduce his members
but first I want to publicly say Mr
Askins we're all rooting for you we know
that you're gonna
win this battle if you're in our
thoughts and prayers and it's good to
see you here today I yield to ranking
member asking
Mr chairman thank you so much it means a
lot to me and I've been gratified to
receive so many kind words of
encouragement and sympathy from
colleagues on both sides of the aisle
and I hope that these expressions of
concern and solidarity will become seeds
of friendship over the year I certainly
plan on getting through this thing and
beating it and I thank you for your
patience and Indulgence
um
so listen
not only
is Jamie Raskin a a beautiful human
being not only is he a talented and uh
just a a fantastic lawyer and
constitutional scholar and expert but he
has a heart and a mind for the American
people he is a patriot for the country
and a patriot for its people
we need more like Jamie Raskin we need
more Democrats like Jamie Raskin and it
would be
an absolute tragedy to lose Jamie Raskin
as a representative
for Maryland
uh I mean there there's a number of
different directions we could talk about
now about Medicare Medicare for all
Universal Health care of whatever form
in this country but I can tell you from
first hand experience
that we need a system change a systemic
change
in the way that we deliver Health Care
in this country I'm sure he's getting
the best of the best care because that
he is a congressman and his the health
care plans up there are Cadillac they
are choice I work for the Senate even
and just as an employee uh it was
amazing I think it cost me twenty
dollars for my son to be born
but uh not everyone is as lucky
even the the the medical bills that my
wife and I are facing right now are
racking up because of the surgery and of
the treatment and everything else that
went in it and I think that we need to
be more Mindful and empathetic of others
who are going through something like
this who don't have the privilege
that Congressman Raskin has that I
indeed have
anyway
um thanks for indulging me a little
personal
um
detour there I appreciate you very much
if you would like to subscribe to my
YouTube channel you can go over just
search my name you can find me on on the
internet on social media I am at Dollar
Moore just about everywhere and of
course I host a twice weekly podcast
with the aforementioned Brittany page my
wife and content creator partner uh
called I doubt it twice weekly podcast
we'd love to see you there
thanks a lot